jamais dû m'en mêler c'est pas mes
affaires non mais vous l'avez fait donc
maintenant ça vous regarde
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait tenez il est
chargé et prenez la tient vous allez lui
ont donné des armes
moi ce que vous allez autres quarts et
les avants marc matin je peux pas vous
emmener vous allez me ralentir quoi
attendent école vous avez vraiment nous
avons donné ici ne s'était pas dans
l'ariège
trouvez vous une planque sanitaire ndour
a fait que vous ne connais rien
on pourra jamais survivre comme martyr
il a décidé de passer in tulle après
tout pourquoi vous avez fait si
maintenant vous nous les accros gala je
préfère avoir une voiture
j'ai une amie qui vit pas très loin on
peut y aller à pied
je vois ça va être depuis des années si
vous nous aidez arriver jusque chez elle
vous aurez sa voiture et vous pourrez
continuer sans nous et elle me laissera
sa voiture ok je vais vous emmener là
bas mais je veux cette voiture j'ai
c'est ok vous restez près de moi vous
faites ce que je dis vous me ralentit
ces jeux vous larguer est-ce que c'est
clair ouais ouais